[Música]
en guatemala la comitiva del presidente
alejandro giammattei fue atacada con
disparos a su paso por una aldea del
departamento de huehuetenango el
presidente salió ileso del incidente
protestas en argentina en buenos aires
decenas de personas manifestaron contra
la agroindustria del país el oficialismo
acusa a los grandes propietarios del
campo de especular con los precios
mientras los agricultores rechazan los
altos impuestos sobre su sector
25 personas murieron en kentucky eeuu
por las inundaciones repentinas de esta
semana el gobernador and diversity
advirtió que los fallecidos pueden
aumentar y que el estado nunca había
vivido una devastación de esta magnitud
bienvenidos a esta edición dedicada a
las noticias más destacadas del
continente americano soy rosa pérez
masdéu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles
empezamos en centroamérica porque este
sábado la comitiva del presidente de
guatemala alejandro giammattei fue
atacada con disparos a su paso por el
departamento de huehuetenango sin
embargo el mandatario salió ileso del
incidente las autoridades detuvieron a
cinco hombres presuntamente responsables
del ataque los detenidos son sospechosos
de pertenecer al cartel nuevo jalisco
que tiene una importante presencia en
esa región
y continuamos en guatemala porque las
autoridades judiciales decretaron
prisión provisional para josé rubén
zamora uno de los periodistas más
críticos con el gobierno de alejandro
giammattei el periodista fue detenido el
viernes la fiscalía lo acusa entre otras
cosas de lavado de dinero zamora se
declaró en huelga de hambre marta moya
con los detalles
un arresto considerado un golpe contra
la libertad de prensa en guatemala
estuvieron en la casa
45 horas
celular
en la noche del viernes el periodista
josé rubén zamora fue detenido por las
autoridades guatemaltecas en medio de un
proceso por presunto lavado de dinero
crítico con el gobierno de alejandro
giammatei el comunicador ya había
anunciado que el gobierno estaba
fabricando un caso para encarcelarle
este sábado zamora se declaró en huelga
de hambre y denunció su captura como una
conspiración y un caso de persecución
política para los defensores de derechos
humanos la detención del periodista
supone una alarma más contra las
libertades en la nación centroamericana
este contexto es alarmante
a su persona defensa de hechos durante
sus clientes son los más vulnerables
actualmente no lo digo sólo yo compro
para derechos humanos lo hizo también la
ch en su informe para 20 europeo el
departamento está eeuu entonces estamos
de alerta pues es importante que los
guatemaltecos y la comunidad
internacional pues estemos atento a
puntos de desarrollo
horas más tarde en entrevista con la
agencia afp el procurador de los
derechos humanos alarmó que la situación
de los derechos en guatemala es cada vez
más parecida a la de nicaragua
a ser fatalistas a la que no tenga boca
de profeta pero pienso que podemos estar
como una nicaragua con un daniel ortega
que se empodera quien participa aquí no
criminalizar los opositores y todo eso
entonces tenemos que estar muy
expectantes de rubén zamora lleva tiempo
denunciando que el gobierno deja mate y
tenga en sus filas a personas señaladas
de ser corruptas por parte de eeuu tras
su detención el reportero continúa a la
espera de que el juez dirima su
situación judicial
y sigue la crisis económica y política
en argentina y uno de los principales
sectores productivos afectados por esta
crisis es el sector agrícola que se
queja de los altos impuestos sin embargo
los oficialistas acusan a la
agroindustria de especular con las
divisas reteniendo la producción el
informe es de samuel salgado
este sábado algunos grupos
progubernamentales se manifestaron en
contra del sector agropecuario
en ese lugar
una política
walter malfatto pertenece a ese sector
es agricultor y produce soya en su finca
al interior de la provincia de buenos
aires- retiene 320 toneladas de su
actual cosecha en estas bolsas de
polietileno como símbolo de protesta a
las altas medidas impositivas de
exportación en el estado del gobierno se
está quedando con 400 dólares y nosotros
ganamos 140 140 eso lo que 140 en pesos
en pesos y bueno es el problema que
tenemos que no liquida el productor su
finca está en la popular pampa húmeda la
región más rica en producción agrícola
argentina debido a la guerra en ucrania
cada tonelada de soya ha vuelto a
alcanzar cotizaciones históricas con
valores superiores a los 600 dólares
pero los granjeros están desmotivados
porque deben descontar de lo que ganan
con cada tonelada entre 31 y 33 por
ciento en solo impuestos aun asi walter
debe seguir vendiendo ya se ve en la
siembra próxima encima tenemos que
vender no no no no no vamos a retener
desde el gobierno de alberto fernández
se acusa al sector agropecuario
principal fuente de divisas del país de
retener 20 mil millones de dólares de
soja para forzar una devaluación del
peso perjudicando a la población más
empobrecida en medio de una inflación
que podría llegar al 76 por ciento este
año según el banco central de argentina
el 30 de julio se celebra el día mundial
contra la trata de personas este tráfico
y sus variantes afectan gravemente al
continente latinoamericano
por cada víctima conocida hay 20 más sin
identificar
números que revelan la incidencia de uno
de los crímenes más perversos de la
humanidad rafael pérez nos cuenta más
es considerada como la actividad
criminal más grande del mundo la trata
de personas es un flagelo que afecta a
millones de personas se está asociada
con el captar o el
tener a una persona con la intención de
utilizarla cierto para fines como de
explotación sexual explotación laboral
servidumbre
trabajos forzados etcétera es una
problemática que a nivel mundial se ha
ido incrementando de las existentes una
predomina en américa latina' digamos la
mayor proporción está asociada a la
explotación sexual no es la única pero
la explotación sexual
afecta de manera
diferenciada a mujeres ya niñas estas se
representan el 80% de los afectados
muchas de ellas no son conscientes de su
condición este azote se acrecentó
durante la pandemia del coronavirus pero
también se implementaron otra forma de
violencia sexual violencia intrafamiliar
y todos estos factores hace que sean más
bulnes y las personas a ser víctimas de
explotación sexual explotación laboral
entre los retos que enfrentan las
instituciones que la combaten se
encuentran los estereotipos culturales
que alimentan la incidencia el
desconocimiento y las nuevas tecnologías
un arma de doble filo que se utiliza
para captar víctimas y también como
instrumento de prevención potencialmente
pedagógico
y terminamos en eeuu donde las
autoridades estatales de kentucky
reportaron que las inundaciones del
pasado miércoles y jueves causaron al
menos 25 fallecidos una cifra que puede
crecer en las próximas horas mientras a
esta hora continúan las labores de
rescate al tiempo que la situación
parece más estable en el terreno
sobrevivir a una verdadera catástrofe
mientras continúa el balance de las
autoridades por las devastadoras
inundaciones que sacudieron el estado
estadounidense de kentucky
los supervivientes relatan cómo lo
vivieron una coste y me hizo levantarme
a las dos y media de la madrugada a las
tres el agua ya se estaba aproximando al
interior de la casa aunque todavía no
estaba dentro en seguida fue acercándose
y el cauce creciendo en un momento dado
miramos a la puerta principal y mi carro
y el de 1.900 estaban jugando los autos
de choque como botes de choque en medio
de nuestro patio delantero según el jefe
de bomberos voluntarios del estado todo
ocurrió muy rápido clifford y merckx
juegos las carreteras se volvieron
intransitables en 30 o 40 minutos lo que
era un leve arroyo o un cauce junto a la
carretera se convirtió en un torrente de
agua y para cuando todo el mundo se
despertó a la mañana siguiente había
vidas destruidas por los perdidos y
gente sin movilidad volver a la guardia
nacional continúa trabajando en las
tareas de rescate al tiempo que las
autoridades estatales ya reportaron
varias decenas de fallecidos cifra que
podría ir en aumento pese a la
estabilización de la situación
en el agua del río a 3 metros las fugas
son casi nulas ya no existe una
situación de peligro y la carretera está
de nuevo abierta todas las vallas han
sido retiradas aquí
las inundaciones de este julio son el
segundo fenómeno climatológico extremo
que vive kentucky en menos de un año los
expertos advierten que estos fenómenos
serán cada vez más recurrentes
muchas gracias por su atención
sigan con nosotros
[Música]